Hello, everyone. This is
doctor Buchan and
we'll be going
through the pre lab
for lab number 27,
which will be diagnosing
the different joints of
the lower extremity.
We're going to get
started with this per
acetabular joint,
which is the hip.
For the hip, we have
a few different
major motions,
which include
flexion extension,
A deduction, A deduction,
external and
internal rotation.
We have a range
of degrees here for
each major motion.
The ranges are going
to vary according to
different sources and
which population
that you're testing,
this would be
the normal range for
30-40-year-old population.
It's just important to
have a general idea
rather than mimorizing
these numbers
when you're comparing
flexion versus
extension or a deduction
versus a deduction.
We also have the
minor joint motions
of the hip.
You have an anterior glide
that happens with
external rotation and
a posterior glide that
happens with
internal rotation.
When you're checking
these motions,
we want to make sure to
compare bilaterally.
So you can compare what is
a physiologic
motion versus
what is a
pathologic barrier.
When we want to test
the hip a deduction,
you're going to do that by
a deducting the hip.
And that is because
if the hip is tight
on the inside,
then that won't
allow us to be
able to pull the leg
out into a deduction.
That is how you
would be able to
test the hip a
deductor muscle.
And you will do the
same thing with
the Abductors by bringing
the leg across midline and
checking the A deduction
range of motion.
When we look at the
hip internal rotators,
we want to bring the leg
into external rotation.
We're going to do that by
bringing the leg and
bending the knee
and at the hip.
The knee will bent
to 90 degrees and
you're going to
hold the knee
and the foot
and externally
rotate by bringing the
leg towards midline.
For internal
rotation, it'll be
a similar position
where the patient
is suprim and again,
the hip and the
knee are bent,
and this time you're
going to bring
the leg out laterally
towards you.
For hip extensors,
you are going
to be testing mainly
the hamstring
and the gluteus maximus.
You could position the
patient as seen in
this photo with the
leg on the shoulder,
or you could place
one hand on the ASIS,
and the other hand on
the leg will raise
the leg up similar
to a straight leg.
Again, you're going
to compare the legs
bilaterally to compare
the degrees of motion.
For testing hip flexion
or the ileostois muscle,
you could do the
Thomas test.
And the leg that you're
going to be testing is
the leg that is
resting on the table.
For the leg that
is straight,
you're going to have
the patient again on
the back and bring
the opposite leg up
towards their
chest and you
want the lumbar spine
to be flat on the table.
You don't want
that increase in
lordosis to prevent
any strain in the back or
skew the Thomas test.
The normal motion
would be if
the thigh is
able to rest on
the table when the knee is
flexed to 90 degrees.
A positive Thomas
test would be
if the thigh is not
able to do this,
it would be off the table.
And then you
could also assess
the quality of
the hip flexors
by placing your hand
on the knee and then
further bending the knee.
We're looking at
the next joint,
the tibiofemoral joint
or the knee joint.
You have these
different dysfunctions,
you have flexion,
extension,
internal rotation, and
external rotation.
The flexion would
be paired with
an anterior glide of
the tibia on the femur.
When people have a
flexion dysfunction,
that could be seen when
they're unable to
flex completely,
and that could be because
the rectus morse muscle is
too tight as seen in
this bottom picture.
With the extension
somatic dysfunction,
you have a
posterior glide and
that's when the patient
is unable to
extend completely,
and that could be because
the handspring
is too tight.
The other two motions,
you want to check
internal and
external rotation
with the knee bent
to prevent walking
at the knee.
With the internal
rotation,
you have a posterior
lateral glide
and with external
rotation,
you have an
anteromedial glide.
This is related to
the shape of the meniscus
and normal joints.
The motions are highield
for board glen.
Moving on to
fibular motion.
We're going to be
checking motion
at the proximal fibula
and the motion is
going to be anterior and
posterior at the
proximal fibula.
The anterior
proximal fibula is
also associated with
an anterior lateral glide.
Whereas the posterior
proximal fibula
is related to a
posterior medial glide.
We can also look at it in
relation to plantar
or dorsiflexion.
If we're looking at
plantar flexion in
this left picture,
We have ptarflexion of
the ankle or the tailus.
Then when that happens,
the lateral malleoli or
the distal fibular
head moves
anteriorly and
since the fibula
has a teeter
tater motion or
a seesaw motion
at either end,
then the proximal
fibular head
would move posteriorly.
With dorsiflexion,
the lateral malleoli is
posterior and that because
of that teeter
ti motion again,
causes the proximals
forehead to move anterior.
Then we're going to
go through that mob.
Next, we have the
tibotilor joint
or the tail,
and we're going to look at
plantar flexion
and dorsiflexion.
The plantar flexion would
be related to an
anterior side,
whereas dorsiflexion
is related
to a posterior side.
And we're going
to be feeling
on top of the tailis
with our thumbs
monitoring right
above and bringing
the ankle
into dorsiflexion
and plantar flexion.
For the tailor calcaneal
joint or the subtil,
you're going to
be stabilizing
the tails with
your top hand
and the bottom hand is
going to be
inducing motion at
the calcaneus and
you're going to
bring it into inversion
and eversion.
Inversion is related to
your posterior
lateral glide
of the tailis on
the calcaneus.
Versus eversion is the
anterior medial glide
of the tailus
on the calcium.
Next,
we have our tarsal
somatic dysfunctions.
We have a plantar glide
when the tarsal bones
are dropping down
towards the sole of
the foot versus
the dorsal glide
where they're stuck up.
For the torsal bones,
you're going to palpate
along the medial edges of
the bones to feel
for whether they have
dropped or feel.
You're going to be feeling
the cuboid and the
radicular and how you
find the cuboid would
be to come along
the fifth
metatarsal and feel
that tuberosity at
the fifth metatarsal,
and then coming slightly
behind that would
be the cuboid bone.
And the navicular would
be right next to it.
This right picture would
be your hand placement
for palpating the cuboid
and the navicular,
again, the medial
edges of those bones.
We're also going
to be palpating
the cumaform.
You can do that by
dropping slightly
lower to where
you were with
the cuboid and
the navicular,
or you could palpate
the metatarsal head
and just come lower
to that for more
proximate to that.
For the metatarsal joint.
You could use this
for restrictions
in either the toes
or the phalanges.
Then there are the three
motions of these joints.
You have the plantar
or the dorsal glide,
internal or
external rotation,
lateral or medial glide.
First, we're
stabilizing the tarsals
proximately with one hand,
and then the other hand
is going to be more
distal and you're going
to take that distal part
into those three
different planes.
Yeah, that's all for
the pre lab lecture.
We have a lot of
different joints
to diagnose.
I hope you enjoy this lab.
Thank you. Enjoy the
rest of your day.